[Musique]
vous croyez peut-être que c'était
adorable chaton que je tiens dans mes
bras elle n'est qu'un vulgaire chaque
coûte cher en fait non pas du tout c'est
un abysse 1 c'est-à-dire une des
peut-être plus vieille race du monde
puisqu'on a retrouvé dans les tombeaux
des pharaons des chats qui est
d'ailleurs déifié à cette époque-là des
chats dont la morphologie se rapprochent
exactement le sel du chaâbi ça
aujourd'hui donc nous allons vous parler
de chat pierre rous les blancs et mal
isolés ou bac vont vous dire la place
que tient le chat dans notre société
moderne vont vous parler des origines du
chat et vont également faire allusion à
la sélection par laquelle l'homme
réussit à créer de nouvelles races de
chats et auparavant je voudrais vous
dire encore une ou deux choses d'abord
que le concours de dessin continue j'en
ai déjà reçu pas mal je vous en
montrerait au prochain magazine
continuer à m'envoyer vos dessins
d'animaux avec une courte légende au
verso si vous voulez partir avec moi en
afrique à la réserve de niokolo koba au
début du mois de mars
et puis également je voudrais vous
signaler que la fédération des sociétés
de protection de la nature organise du
22 au 27 novembre
le chat n'a pas voulu rester avec moi du
22 au 27 novembre une grande opération
appelée sologne vivante
il s'agit de la création en sologne
d'une réserve qui sera ouverte au public
d'ailleurs et d'un centre d'initiation
nature alors pour aider à la création de
cette réserve réservé un bon accueil à
ceux qui vous proposeront des timbres
selon vivante et des cartes de noël et
maintenant nous allons rejoindre maryse
offenbach et pierre rous les blancs et
les six cents chats que madame ravel a
réuni aux quatre clubs de paris si nous
avons profité du cadre exceptionnel
qu'offre cette exposition internationale
du calcium de paris pour présenter cette
émission qui est à paraître capitule
hâtif de toutes les émissions que vous
avez fait jusqu'à présent sur les chats
et c'est aussi un peu un centenaire
puisque droit que la première
manifestation de ce genre a eu lieu en
1871 à londres et en crystal palace
oui et puis c'est l'exposition faut bien
le souligner il n'avait pas la variété
est considérable de race d'espèces que
nous avons ici
il avait en réalité si si je sept races
et variétés lentilles nous avons 48 et
c'est une très très longue histoire que
l'évolution du chat à travers les âges
allez vous dire qu'on a fait de la filme
technique alors d'anticiper parce que
les chinois croisé déjà les chats
le premier ça alors là vous me posez un
petit peu une
une colle parce que les mystères de
l'origine du chien on en discute encore
je peux vous donner la version légende
la version légende qui est qui se passe
sur l'arche de noé bien entendu et une
chasse rennais d amour dans un singe qui
s'ennuyer d'une lionne frais
complaisante
moi j'ai une autre légende pour moi le
chat est également menée dans l'arche de
noé mais dans cet avion qui a été retenu
et qui a donné naissance à deux familles
assure je n'ai pas si l'une ou l'autre
sont vraiment toujours dit que les
hommes de science sont beaucoup moins
précis que nous dans ce domaine y font
remonter le chat à divers chats sauvages
j'avoue que j'en ai sélectionné deux qui
me paraissaient à peu près probable
c'était le chat de le shaq gantés de
chaque antenne ubi pour ce qui était des
chats européen et le chama nul pour ce
qui était des chats asiatiques
bien entendu ça ne
on ne répond pas absolument à toutes les
classifications par exemple le chat
angora ne rentre pas dans cette
classification notamment pour le saut
plages qui ne se retrouve que dans cette
région de perth quête angora bien
entendu on ne peut pas s'arrêter on chat
sans parler des mutations
parce que à partir de ces races primaire
bien entendu on n'aboutit pas
directement au château nous connaissons
maintenant alors d'abord il ya eu des
mutations d'une mutation c'est une
transformation brutale qui fait qu'un
chat aperçu que par exemple vous change
de poils et que sais tu ce changement
devient héréditaire devient définitif et
puis il ya autre chose il y à
l'accoutumance à un certain climat
incertain territoire qui fait que le
chat s'habitue c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sélection naturelle
évidemment il ya l'homme alors là on
commence à s'intéresser aux chats
l'homme commence à s'intéresser aux
chats très tôt et le domestique
il est domestique d'abord pour chasser
en particulier pour chasser les souris
et ça reste pratiquement le seul rôle du
chat jusqu'au 19ème siècle et au 19e
siècle
on en revient à cette exposition c'est
les anglais qui les premiers s'intéresse
aux charmilles à ce moment là au point
de vue esthétique au point de vue ça
parce que finalement les premiers chat
retombe à une exposition comme celle de
talent
montrer aujourd'hui on est surtout
frappé par la variété des fourrures et
les couleurs à l'époque il n'y avait pas
de cette variété de couleurs les chats
étaient souvent tabbee ou bruns ou roux
oui bien entendu mais justement
leshop.ch à la nuit tous les chats sont
gris saisi le dicton et c'est vrai tous
les chats se ressent le plus ou moins
ils ont la même morphologie en général
alors les éleveurs se sont heurtés quand
même un problème si les chiens par
exemple dans la vie des grands vins et
les petits dés long des cours des liens
mais sur le museau écrasé bien accueilli
au museau long on peut faire des tas de
croisement chez le chat il restait pas
grand chose d'autre que la fourrure que
la couleur et c'est là dessus que la
finale de technique s'est attaché à
essayer de donner découle des
colorations nouvel an partant des
déchets alimentaires être nous montrer
ça sur le cirma que tout le monde
connait je vais remettre ce chaton avec
sa famille voulait peut-être leur place
et voilà voilà alors ici nous avons le
siamois non pas le siamois d'origine ils
se rapprochent beaucoup le cinéma
d'origine on ne sait pas très bien ce
qu'ils étaient dans le fond je crois que
c'était un chien qui était plutôt un
chat de musées anciens d'exposition
ambitieux d'ailleurs on l'a laissé
longtemps dans des cages pour un genre
ainsi les quais au jardin des plantes et
aux à l'origine en regardée comme une
bête curieuse
c'est pas du tout je crois qu'il a fallu
attendre que la belle-fille de sadi
carnot s'y intéressent personnellement
pour considérer que c'était un achat
merveilleux et qui est aujourd'hui un
des plus beaux enfin c'est ça parce
qu'il ya eu la mode il ya une anna de la
mode c'est de booster brutalement ont
pas réussi à moi et on a fait ce qu'il
est maintenant
alors là c'est d'abord et jusqu'en 10 à
153 6 un type y est le cil pointe que
vous voyez ici avec toute cette
charmante famille et puis et l'a fait
également le chocolate punk qui est à
une variation un petit peu celui là mais
au lieu d'être
les silhouettes en fait ce sont des
colorations c'est la couleur du masque
et de la pauvreté ça
le terme de forme que de test de pointe
à a trait à cette coloration jeu là que
de la tête et du masque alors ceci c'est
juste qu'en 58 ans 58 on a eu d'autres
siamois ou que l'on voit à venir de
notre expulsion il a beaucoup c'est très
rare nous avons des lilas nous avons des
raids
nous avons des habits des tables polt et
des écailles points
[Musique]
l'histoire de la joie de la fabrication
de ces personnes que leurs fonds
illustre bien ce que vous désirez canola
lieu la complexité du travail des
éleveurs face qu'à l'origine pour ce
qu'on voulait c'était donc c'est un
siamois aux poils longs et qui aura fait
le contraire on a créé à personne avec
les poils du siamois exactement c'est il
ya un petit peu de cuisine là dedans
c'est vraiment quelquefois on aboutit au
résultat opposé puis on dit qu'on a fait
une formidable découverte
mais là c'en est une est effectivement
comme vous dites on voulait créer un
siamois mai
il faut bien dire que avant celui là et
ça illustre aussi ce que nous disions
tout à l'heure il y en a quatorze
d'avoir autant de roms
j'ai envie vous avez un oui ça c'est
très féminin
mais pour en revenir au persan s'ils
voulaient au départ n'étant été
certainement très simple le persan qui a
ramené pietro della valle au xvième
siècle était quelque chose de d'une
couleur simple et ce chat a évolué on ne
sait comment
jusqu'au moment où l'homme s'y est
intéressé pour sa sélection et il a fait
un personnes noires un père semblant il
a fait les versants il a sélectionné la
couleur des yeux pour la sortir à la
robe qui est en plus contesté
c'est ça le persan noir a les yeux
orange ce qui est très difficile à
obtenir c'est surtout le noir t davies
et d'obtenir parce que ce noir ne doit
absolument avoir aucun reflet et doit
être moi j'ai vraiment absolue ça c'est
un truc que cette année et puis les
chats blancs alors dans les chats blancs
il ya ici aussi une question dieu il ya
des chats blancs aïeux orange
il ya des chats blancs qui ont les yeux
bleus ils sont effectivement le jeune
blanc plus vieux bleus est souvent sa
sortie à la surdité et puis vous avez
des paires semblant qu'ils ont avec bleu
médailles or en ce qu'on appelle des
chats verront ils sont reconnus par la
fédération mais absolument absolument je
ne sais pas ça ici une oreille sont
reconnus par la fédération
dans le sillon poursuit l'étude de ces
couleurs de persan on a déjà beaucoup
plus sophistiqué on avait ce manque et
sa wii exactement mais il est un peu
détrôner maintenant parce qu'on appelle
le chinchilla le persan chinchilla
évidemment qui est aussi également un
des plus chers si vous avez des persans
un peu plus bizarre qu'on voit moins
souvent et notamment le père sans
écailles notant qu est le père sans
écailles et blanc tous
il aurait pu devenir des personnes on
s'est aperçu que la couleur écaille
c'est à dire une couleur qui est beige
et noir ainsi que la couleur écaille et
blanche est assorti d'une certaine
féminité d'une féminisation de
du gène vous savez je pense qu'on peut
dire que le personnage est un peu le
chat des mille et une nuits on rêve tout
simplement posséder mais leur entretien
est extrêmement compliqué oh là là oh là
là je me souviens d'une émission sur le
persan où j'avais un beau costume foncé
qui il ne m'a été très difficile de
faire nettoyer ensuite bien vite du poil
de personnes partout alors je ne sais
pas s'il ya des gens qui ont des
moquettes foncé chez eux ils ont un père
semblant ça doit leur problème on peut
leur poser des problèmes d'aspirateurs
considérable je crois que les hommes
forts de cette exposition nous allons
avoir quelques détails ce toilettage
très minutieux
finalement madame marolles je crois que
ce qui est le plus difficile c'est j'ai
un chat c'est de l'entretenir c'est son
toilettage surtout lorsque c'est un chat
qui a des poils aussi long que celui la
oui évidemment le problème du doigt les
tâches pour le guen l'on est très
important cette dame va 'qualité son
chat là devant vous pour vous montrer
exactement ce qu'il faut faire
la brosse le peignent la poudre et cette
opération se répète tous les jours et
tous les jours en principe oui
alors évidemment avant les expositions
le toilettage est encore plus minutieux
affaire est ce que vous aviez quelques
conseils à donner à ce propos pour le le
toilettage madame c'est vous qui doit
laisser vos chats est ce que vous vous
l'invitez de faire mieux encore les
poils longs jeux les jeux les peignes au
moins trois fois par semaine et quand je
les amène à l'exposition jeu les bennes
trois jours avant nous sommes pas un
trop gros travail
non parce qu'on les aime et comme on
veut venir au concours ou qu'elle soit
jolie est alors de toute façon on le
fait quand même
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
bien marlies puisque vous avez l'air si
ferrer au point de vue chat je vais vous
poser une conne qu'est ce que c'est que
ce soit je ne suis pas collé parce que
ce n'est pas ainsi à moi et ce n'est pas
non plus un persan et c'est un chat
sacré de guerre monique savez je
reconnais à la pâte comme voila voila ce
chat sacré de birmanie qui effectivement
ressent fort un père de personne que
leur faune ou un 6ème ou à poils longs
comme vous l'aimez la seule différence
c'est justement cette coloration blanche
des pâtes et vous savez que c'est une
légende une très jolie légende
baissez vous la raconter mais en fait
ça remonte à très très loin il y avait
un vieux beau ce bien avant la naissance
du bouddha et ça se passait quelque part
en birmanie y avait un vieux rose qui
avait un chat tout blanc cette époque
et quand il a senti qu'ils approchaient
de la mort cet homme qui était un prince
un homme s'est couché aux frais de la ds
qui était représentée par une idole d'or
avec des yeux très bleus et qui était la
déesse de la réincarnation
quand il est mort son âme sur les gens
dépassés dans le corps du chat blanc le
ch a d'ailleurs a immédiatement sauté
sur la tête du saint homme et son
accoururent est devenu or comme le corps
dorée de la ds ses yeux sont devenus
bleus comme les yeux de sa fille de
celle de cette idole et seul le bout des
pattes est resté blanc parce qu'il est
elle reposait sur la tête de cet homme
qui était
écrit les légendes qui ont investi
beaucoup mieux que tout ce qu'on peut
nous raconter au point de vue hérédité
moi je voudrais ajouter une chose en
tout cas sur les virements
je peux vous dire une chose c'est que
les birman sont les amoureuses les plus
épouvantables les plus frénétiques qu'on
puisse rencontrer chez les chiens et ça
ça rend quelques fois les castrations du
gap ouvert et si vous voulez finir là
jusqu'à présent nous avons un peu parlé
problème d'élevage qu'on passe à une
cuisine tout à l'heure je reprendrai
terme mais il faut quand même profiter
du cadre de cette exposition pour se
promener un peu parmi les différents cas
j'ai visité des chiens que nous
n'aurions jamais eu l'occasion de voir
autrement oui bien sûr je crois que ici
nous avons des chats c'est exceptionnel
qui sont les chefs notes ou à vannes qui
sont des chats qui vont directement issu
du siamois part
différentes différents mélanges assez
compliqué ce sont des chats qui sont
bruns qui ont les yeux très vert le
prime devrait aussi venir a encore dit
sur un souci de l'esthétique et tout ça
se fait oui bien sûr alors vous avez
vous avez un côté un ami un autre chat
qui peut aisément se confondre qui est
le burmese qui lui seraient repartis
avec dire non à leur actionnariat
absolument pas absolument pas et
pourtant alors je me demande comment ils
ont fait cet effet harvard
ils ont croisé des siamois et des
burmese ils ont obtenu ce chat qui a une
coloration soit brune soit qu'on appelle
zibeline soie bleue avec contrairement à
eau à vannes que nous voulons voir qui
allait lui les yeux peux pas et je vois
pas du tout le rapport entre les
virements et
le siam washington en croisement comment
on peut obtenir une chose est sûre de
vous dire en tous les cas c'est que les
siamois n'a pas laissé son nom alors que
le birman il s'appelait bas aux voiliers
lancer des choses
d'un côté c'est dommage que j'ai pas le
professeur le tard à côté parce qu'il
pourrait d'une part les ce chat qui est
leur ex parce que c'est lui qui a été
conservateur qui a été à l'origine de
cet animal était jeu direct mais il
s'agit plutôt d'un type de fourrure vous
allez viens on va en regardant ce chat
que là aussi je le regarde avec un peu
dormi parce qu'il porte sur le taux
l'astrakan 13 mai à midi oui d'ailleurs
on l'appelle aussi chez aastra quand
vous voyez cette fourrure est réduit il
n'y a pas de quoi elle de chasse une
forme très particulière
mais il faut dire une chose c'est que
cette fourrure est parfaitement
transmissibles à toutes races de chats
par croisements et ont confié avoir les
terres sans leur ex ou des n'importe
quoi ils soient pas il faudrait s'y
intéresser je pense que ça ne va pas
tarder au train où va maintenant on fait
un peu n'importe quoi j'avais dit on
fait beaucoup de choses avec les chats
et déjà ici nous avons deux rex de
couler à différentes d'ailleurs nous
avons inscrit et en exclu brin une jambe
ou rayé mais nous avons parlé des chars
av
il ya tout de même plus parce que ceux
qui nous écoutent
l'emprunt se demander ce qu'on fait de
leur chat de gouttière de leur bateau
n'a pas la place ici ou à 10,1 là ils
sont là c'est ce qu'on appelle les chats
européen là là là je dois dire la
supériorité des chiens sur les faits
ainsi que le chien bâtard non aucune
aucun droit de figurer dans des
expositions à leur échelle du tiers ou
une ou des standards je voudrais bien
qu'il existe un club du cormier xiam
enfin ça c'est très très confidentiel
mais effectivement il ya un standard de
l'européen
comment et dans une des expositions
comme celle ci classe ton les chats on
nous aide pas perdus vous faites
semblant là puisque vous savez très bien
qu'il ya deux catégories de chiens les
chats à poils courts et les chats à
poils longs
joyce est assez simpliste mais on n'a
pas su comment faire autrement à une
morphologie il ya une morphologie mais
qui va se retrouver surtout dans le fait
qu'ils sont soit exotiques soit européen
et la différence et le siamois avec la
chine a fait triangulaire une question
de traite uniquement et l'européen
c'est un choc à la tête assez ronde
c'est un media line si vous voulez
employer des mots techniques le passage
un petit peu parce qu'il a la tête très
très rond et puis là
l'uson légèrement enfoncé il s'en
prendre et ils sont bien entendu main
mais ceci étant dit c'est la
classification la plus simple quand on
peut qu'on puisse trouver parce que je
vous dis étant donné que tous les chats
morphologiquement sont à peu près
identiques on ne peut les différencier
par les questions de détail les
questions de plage ou à la rigueur au
centre de la terre mois les juges
doivent savoir un travail horrible orale
et pc oui d'ailleurs ça alors ça c'est
pas du tout mon domaine et je crois
qu'il serait préférable d'aller demander
à madame ravenne
quelques juges il nous explique un peu
comme mon frère monsieur jean madness
vous êtes heures landais et vous jugez
habituellement en suisse alors ma
première question sera celle ci est ce
que on fait juger des expositions
nationales toujours par des juges
étrangers non ne fait pas toujours mais
en suisse comme aussi dans les autres
pays
dans les expositions internationales on
demande justement
davant les juges des autres pays pour
avant un meilleur jugement sur dish d'un
souci d'objectivité
alors comment comment jugez-vous sur
quels critères vous basez vous pour
décider qu'un chat est beau ou qui ne
l'est pas chaque race chaque variété un
standard allemand et ce standard ça fait
100 points pour les crèmes disons c'est
le poil qui représente 50 points la tête
20 points il ya désormais les yeux
la structure du corps ça fait un tour ça
fait 100 points
n'est ce pas alors ce chat que vous avez
entre les mains
combien de points lui donneriez vous
celui ci ça c'est un oui on peut presque
dire c'est un chaque préfet
d'après le jugement que je peux en faire
96 points 96 points sur 100 c'est donc
un champion champion des champions en
vie il ya une certaine distance entre
les halls et qui va faire
la tête doit être très bombée
le nez nous appelons ça c'est le stock
le menton doit être bien formé
paraîtrait mais jusqu aux mines est ici
il va avoir une ossature assez forte en
ehpad combrié une peu
ah si courte donc mesuré dans une
certaine mesure affaibli comme ceci
qu'on lui mettre sur le dos pour la vie
près le marché du coin
la structure du coup il doit être à vue
oui en tout cas maintenant comment ce
n'est pas encore la saison
comme au mois de décembre janvier mai
oui le coin est temps pour le
débarrasser cours
et ça lui donne autrement et lui manque
la collerette qui se fait naturellement
ici autour de la tête commune
holy très difficile de dire que
on aime un chat mieux qu'un autre en
regardant tous les chats qui sont
présents à cette exposition
mais tout de même quand je regarde les
poils ras lyonnais qui me frappe par la
pureté de céline c'est le chaâbi sein
est très semblable à certaines statues
c'est du lourd
eh bien oui vous savez que l'abyssin on
le fait remonter à la haute antiquité
égyptienne on prétend que c'est l'image
très très fidèle de ses chats qui a
accompagné les pharaons dans leur vie
quotidienne et qui était pratiquement
des initiés aux rites et il ya une autre
hypothèse qui est plus terre-à-terre
bien entendu c'est celle des hommes de
science qui disent que c'est les anglais
qui ont fait ce chat très récemment et
qui n'a absolument rien à voir avec
l'échelle soutien ceci étant dit moi je
préfère quand même la légende du chat
égyptien elle est très belle et puis
ensuite lé vl à mon avis elle est
véridique
parce que il a existé des chats
d'abyssinie il a existé un type qui
c'est qui ces deux cas et vous qui a
évolué mais qui a évolué toujours
danseuse dans ce soit ce type de
morphologie qu'est la baie st s'est
parlé tout à l'heure
là aussi pour les lycéens on le voit
très nettement nasa tout rires oui on
voit très nettement surtout dans
lorsqu'il s'agit de la vie sain lièvre
dans l'habit sa roue ça se voit moins
bien qu'elle soit en trois petites
bandes noires à l'extrémité de la
fourrure qui donne cette espèce de
coloration mixte c'est exactement ça je
crois vous allez pouvoir bientôt examiné
les additions de plus près parce que
vous allez en avoir un vous apercevrez
que ce sont des chats absolument
adorable absolument gentille très
intelligente des chats un petit peu
chien qui vous suivent un peu partout
vous savez je crois que l'on pourrait
pas on pourrait parler éternellement des
chats y en a tellement dans cette
exposition il y en a simplement deux que
je voudrais signaler avant de terminer
le petit tour que nous allons faire il y
en a deux encore ils se ressemblent
c'est le bleu russe et le fameux chat
chartreux
serez vous dites qu'il te reste en moi
j'ai pas du tout d'accord parce que le
char toi c'est un gros chat massif avec
une tête carrée paris ce que le virus
d'après exact mais ça vous pensez ça
parce que vous vous conseille tout de
suite moines
bien qu'aucune au chat chartreux n'est
pas forcément au buzz c'est
on peut aussi élancée qu'un bleu russe
la seule différence est que le bleu
russe lui est un chat exotique à tête
triangulaire
alors que le fils a les yeux verts et
puis le chartreux lui est un chat
européen qui a les yeux
tapage aussi ce qu'il faut signaler sur
le chartreux c'est que c'est un chat qui
a eu une triste réputation parce qu'il a
une fourrure qui est tellement jolie est
tellement dense qu'il ya des tas de gens
qui mal intentionnés qui avons fait
l'élevage pour faire madame de vos
manteaux de fourrure je vais vous
demander si vous étiez également
d'accord avec la légende qui veut que le
chartreux et été amenés par des moines
et près de chartres est justement
l'afrique du sud pour chasser les sur
bulot qui will à leurs cadres oui
pourquoi laisser tout aux anglais là
aussi les envier veulent le chartreux il
appelle le british blues maintenant
vient nous on ne sait les moines de
saint bruno qui ont amené ce chat mais
je n'en démordrai pas on ne peut pas
quitter cette exposition sans parler des
étranges rapport qui ont toujours lié
l'homme et le chat c'est curieux parce
que dans l'ancien dans l'antiquité il a
été souvent déifié dit souders moyen-âge
et a été voué aux démons ces rapports
sont mystérieuses et après les mystères
du challenge vous savez on retrouve ça
actuellement
actuellement vous avez des chats des
pardons actuellement vous avez des eaux
qui vont vous dire moi je hais les chats
qui ne supporte pas le contact physique
d'un chat ni le nil de penser à un chat
exactement comme on peut avoir une
aversion vis-à-vis des serpents si vous
avez des un endroit qui tombé en syncope
c'était henry tron et vous avez aussi
des gens qui voulaient vous avez un chat
chez vous je ne comprends pas comment on
pouvait avoir un animal aussi hypocrite
paresseux malsain alors cela évidemment
je pense qu'ils ne connaissent pas très
bien le chat ils n'ont pas fait l'effort
de que de connaître cet animal et parce
que lorsqu'on passe alors dans l'autre
camp celui des amis des chats alors dans
ce crime un exemple historique par
exemple sur lesquelles avait 4 ans 14
personnes qui ont élevé au blanc plaît
six ans il est
dans 6 v séries quand on passe dans
l'autre camp qui voulait la vous en
faites une hélistation on tombe pas
remis on est en très bonne compagnie
rouler en compagnie de gens de lettres
et écrivains dans les temps en compagnie
d'artistes vous voyez depuis par son
commerce de reins les chats qui ensuite
du bellay le tas sa suite chateaubriand
victor hugo et plus près de nous paul
léautaud colère et un manteau à la
poussée jour là alors de là à dire que
le ch est un plaisir d'intellectuels
destin il n'y a qu'un pas est ce pas je
le franchirai allègrement le franchir
allègrement parce que je pense que pour
aimer un chat il faut une certaine
transcendance intellectuelle disons que
pour aimer un chat ce volet il faut un
postulat il faut quatre postulants il
faut que le chat vous accès premier
postulat ce n'est pas toujours un
pas toujours facile à résoudre le
deuxième c'est que vous ayez acquis
cette connaissance c'est que l'essence
du chat qui veut que pour que cet animal
vous aime et vous respecte il faut que
vous aussi vous le respecter et que vous
l'aimiez en conséquence ensuite il faut
avoir cette connaissance qui fait que
c'est un être libre indépendant et puis
qu'il faut le regarder évoluer il faut
avoir ce choc esthétique du félin que ce
soit à la vue que ce soit la caresse que
ce soit la manière dont une aux
tunisiens vers vous et dans le fond
c'est pas un animal qui est très
accaparant c'est un peu un plaisir
d'égoïste le chat est vous dire est ce
qu'il ya on peut donner à un caractère
gens qui aiment les chats et il ya des
traits communs ceux qui les aiment et à
ceux qui préfèrent les chiens vont
conduire là je vais pas me renier me
hasarder tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que l'on rencontre chez le chat
chez les amateurs de chats un fanatisme
beaucoup plus grand que chez les
amateurs de chiens lorsque l'amour du
chat
s'élève il s'élève toujours très très
haut ils s'élèvent d'ailleurs ton
quelquefois ce qui fait la mauvaise
réputation de certaines personnes qui
s'intéressent un peu trop coucha et
convoque un peu le gentiment ya tout de
même un phénomène qu'on va passer sous
silence si c'est la prolifération de
certains chats abandonnés qu'on
rencontre aurait terrain vague
là on voit des salles d'exposition mais
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont des chats
est finalement qu il ait l'est qui les
abandonne oui parle si si chéri chez les
chiens le deviendra se développent et on
abandonne de moins en moins de chiens
parce que justement on a de plus en plus
de chiens de race qui ont coûté un
certain prix il faut bien entendu
malheureusement faire intervenir une
question de prix les jardins publics des
grandes villes
l'espoir les démolitions sont plaints de
chats errants malheureux qui se
reproduisent qui se reproduit qui se
reproduisent et qu il n y en a plus d'un
million en france que si les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes alors moi je vais
quand même donné un conseil d'alsace et
le vétérinaire qui va de nouveau
reprendre la parole c'est d'abord
lorsque vous avez un chat une chaque que
vous avez l'intention de les faire
reproduire
eh bien il faut les faire reproduire de
manière diriger il faut faire de delà du
contrôle des naissances
parce que vous ne trouverez jamais assez
de gens susceptibles de s'intéresser à
vos chats de manière sérieuse
donc il faut les castrais au coeur et ça
il faudra soit éliminé les portes et les
individus déportés c'est mon père soit
castrés mâles et femelles donc on va
voir dans des biens merci beaucoup
rousselet je tiens aussi à remercier
madame ravel grâce à qui cette très
belle exposition a eu lieu
et grâce à qui aussi l'émission a eu
lieu sont bien le dire
et peut-être nous retrouverons nous tous
dans un an puisque ces expositions ont
lieu annuellement sur votre oeil une
rampe à 600 et 700
les nouveaux d'ailleurs des événements
nouveaux
[Musique]